bon ben ok mais au juste pourquoi un
maître mesure 1 m
tout ça c'est une histoire de système
international d'unités en gros des
mesures communes pour que tout le monde
parle de la même chose
tout se mesure en maître souvent bien
manier et au libéria et aux états unis
lemaitre à trouver une définition en
pas si simple écoutez plutôt oui le 10
millionième du quart du méridien très
exactement voilà se met très connue sous
le nom de maître étalon à la couture
annoncé qu'elle travaille il faudre et
ben non le mètre étalon c'est cette
barre de platine qui mesure le 10
millionième du quart du méridien un
exemplaire est conservé dans le pavillon
de breteuil à sèvres à l'abri de
l'humidité et de la lumière
sauf que se mettre là pour faire pile
poil un m il lui manque un dix millième
de millimètre alors 1960 nouvelle
définition
accrochez vous à la transition entre les
niveaux d'eau bénite et pang et tang de
la tombe donc les plantes capables comme
chez sal c'est simple c'est simple on
s'en moque parce qu'en 1983 la
conférence des poids et mesures a décidé
de changer la définition du maître car
il lui manque quelques microns pour être
exact
la longueur du trajet parcouru dans le
vide par la lumière en 1 2 million 999
722 458 yens 1 selon une mesure
effectuée dans le vide donc universel
d'un point de vue scientifique quelle
que soit l'altitude la pression etc
mais dix ans après pas question pour les
ingénieurs d'en rester là
nous sommes en train de réaliser des
expériences de spectroscopie laser afin
d'essayer d'améliorer la définition du
maître il est défini dans un certain
intervalle d'incertitude et on essaie
justement de réduire cet intervalle tout
ça paraît abstrait mais c'est quand même
plus simple de mesurer des distances
avec une valeur universelle plutôt
qu'avec des pousses des pieds et des
verges
parce que oui yard ça se traduit par
[Musique]
oh